[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and run all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me
I have my regular old canvas here wet
and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty two-inch brush
here whack that off a little bit just
beat it like it owes you money we're
gonna get a little damp or yellow snow
here mix that with just another little
dab of our baby white now well that's
just dancin happy little C I remember
this is your world you get to make and
break the rules here sweet baby Jesus
wish I could jump in there and roll
around and all that cascading white
powder yeah just get high and all of
life's splendor God I love cocaine so
much holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a
kite right now okay let's paint it a few
little heavy trees there nothing wrong
with making friends with trees now what
you don't want to do is eat these paints
trust me on this one all right I'm gonna
whack off again that's right that feels
good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams wet and remember hugs
not drugs
[Music]